تُظهر مشاهد من الجبهة الجنوبية لأوكرانيا خلال الأشهر الأولى من الحرب ، والتي تمت
مشاركتها حصريًا مع
قناة سي إن إن ، الملازم الأول الأوكراني أندريه بيدليسني وهو يختبئ في فوهات القذيفة تحلق
بطائرة بدون طيار لاستدعاء ضربات مدفعية على
مواقع روسية
[موسيقى]
لكن فريق المراقبين نجا بصعوبة أيضًا.
- نيران من الجيش الروسي
بعد أشهر من تصوير مقاطع الفيديو هذه ،
لا يزال بيدليسني يقاتل على
الجبهة الجنوبية ،
حيث كان الروس في هذه القرية قبل
أن يقاتل الجيش الأوكراني
لاستعادة الأراضي
، تتم معالجتها ببطء شديد
لاستعادة جميع أراضينا ولكن خطوة
بخطوة  خطوة وبمساعدة
البنادق الغربية الأضعف وهكذا في أنظمة المدفعية
، سافرنا أنا وفريقي
على طول الجبهة الجنوبية
من ميناء أوديسا الحرج
إلى حافة منطقة دونباس ،
تحدثت إلى أشخاص على استعداد للمخاطرة
حياتهم ضد آلة الحرب الروسية
في مدينة بريبيري القوات الأوكرانية
تقتحم مبنى
انها بالفعل  تمرين تدريبي
لإعداد هؤلاء الرجال لواحد من
أخطر أشكال القتال الحضري للحرب الحديثة ،
أصيب القائد هنا بجروح خطيرة
ودفع الانفصاليين المدعومين
من روسيا إلى خارج المدن في منطقة دونباس الشرقية
في عام 2014. لقد اختلسنا
واجب تحريرنا.
المناطق التي
يقول إنها أرضنا ولن نمنحها
لأي شخص
تلك الثقة التي يتقاسمها فوج من
قوات الخطوط الأمامية في شرق أوكرانيا
التي يتباهون بها مؤخرًا
لاند روفر بريطانية الصنع
وناقلة الجنود المدرعة هذه ،
لقد لاحظت للتو شيئًا ما يتطلب  انظر
هنا
إلى هذا الإطار
المصنوع في روسيا ،
كان روسيًا ، لقد كانت سيارة روسية ،
لكن
جنودنا
قاتلوه
وأخذوا هذه السيارة التي استولت عليها ،
لكن الحرب تتسبب في خسائر مروعة
هنا
ليلًا ونهارًا بالصواريخ الروسية s-300
سطح-إلى-  تم إعادة توجيه الصواريخ الجوية
لضرب أهداف أرضية
تلاحق مدينة ميكولايف على خط المواجهة
ويبدو أن المزيد في الطريق الذي
شاركت فيه مجموعات المقاومة الأوكرانية هذه
اللقطات الحصرية مع  التُقطت CNN
قبل أيام فقط تظهر وصول قطار
مليء بالصواريخ إلى
منطقة هرسان الجنوبية المحتلة ، وأكدت
لاحقًا صور الأقمار الصناعية هذه التي قدمتها
CNN بواسطة
Maxar ولكن بمساعدة صواريخ بعيدة المدى من الولايات المتحدة
تعرف باسم Highmars ، كانت أوكرانيا تستهدف روسيا.
يقول الملازم أول بيدليسني في مستودعات الذخيرة إنه
لاحظ اختلافًا في الخطوط الأمامية
كان لدينا حوالي أسبوعين وثلاثة أسابيع عندما
لم يكن لديهم
ذخيرة كافية لقتالنا ،
ولا يزال يتوقع أن يستغرق
أوكرانيا وقتًا طويلاً للفوز بالحرب في
الجنوب.  لست متأكدا من أننا سنفوز حتى
نهاية هذا العام
ربما حتى نهاية العام المقبل